humor me I'd like to thank the academy  um I've always wanted to say that um  there are a lot of people that i want to  thank but most importantly I want to  talk about my crew Jenna ang Isaac  Gracie Lawrence loose key and my saving  grace live Larson kept my brain in my  head during this production it was two  and a half months of insane production  post production filming all at once my  mom is actually here of course i want to  thank her she came all the way from  Michigan this is the first time this has  ever happened for Michigan State  University but most importantly I want  to thank the citizens of Flint for  trusting us with their story in this  time of crisis that's what the Flint  water crisis is a crisis and it is still  actively going on in Michigan they have  lead in their water but also copper  chloroform and huge growing bacterial  colonies so I beg each and every one of  you to not forget Flint and the story  that I've told here thank you